i recently read an article
talking about how cern was
experimenting with their collider trying
to make
their own encapsulated black holes
is this true uh look yes in one says yes
theoretically so they would love to be
able to
make these what we refer to as
quantum black holes or primordial black
holes
quantum black holes or primordial yeah
okay so they're called quantum because
they're incredibly small
okay okay um we're not talking about the
black holes that we have it's
interesting we talk about this
um i'm not sure if you're aware but the
nobel prize for physics was only
announced
uh 12 hours ago was it really yeah
yeah and roger penrose um got half of
that prize
for his work on the black hole so the
black hole understanding prior to the
work of roger penrose and
stephen hawking was just a theoretical
model
based on einstein's work on relativity
but it was penrose and hawking who
really established the fact
yes nothing they can exist it's not a
hypothetical
and the other two recipients their name
escapes me right now
basically their work was on
discovering a black hole in the center
of our galaxy
but let me let me give you an idea here
what the black hole is i think that's
important
because a lot of people think black hole
is massive gobbly big giant thing that's
swapping up all matter around it
and you know movies like interstellar
show you that but there have been lots
of other movies that
have used that as a almost a horror
effect yeah andrew steller was a
was a great one oh that's it's one of my
favorites
uh and it actually is uh
one of the few movies that got the
physics right and it helped really
help yeah and the reason why is that the
book is
it's based on a book by kip thorne and
kip thorne is a cosmologist
astrophysicist
and he was very clear with chris nolan
he said look i i get this is a creative
license
required in the movie right but you
can't break the laws of physics you must
you must stick to laws of physics but
you can't break that and so chris nolan
uh followed that and so as a result
a lot of the physics in the movie is
very true
very accurate in terms of time dilation
and all sort of stuff it is so it is so
i had to watch it like three times just
to understand and grasp what was
happening and how
the dad didn't age a day but his
daughter
aged 100 years and he was changing
history that's almost impossible to
explain to somebody if you're having a
regular conversation
it is it was it is and uh and yet
we know that we you know we digress away
from this
black hole stuff after a second but um
the fact is is that we know that to be
true
so you know how uh the dad
doesn't age right the time passes
differently
than for the daughter on earth right
right the fact the fact is that your gps
machine on your phone works at all
is because of that principle let me
explain
gps is basically resultant of a set of
satellites in orbit around the earth in
low earth orbit
but at any point there are four
satellites that have direct line of
sight
to your phone and so they send signals
back and forth
to your receiver and to the phone and
use a process of what we call
trilateration it's basically
triangulation
if you can know the distance from those
satellites then the satellites in your
phone can work out its position
right okay and so it's basically trying
you know if you draw
three circles right there's only one or
two points where those circles all
intersect
right and so if you know the distance of
those circles
you can work out where you are in terms
of that position
but that requires exceptionally good
time keeping the satellites must be
completely in sync of time
because otherwise they can't work out
your distance so
the problem is is that the satellites
are moving
but you're not relative least to the
earth and so the
satellite because it's in orbit right
it actually ages slower
than you or i now it's not like
interstellar where there's
major differences here the earth's
gravitational pull isn't like a black
hole
so as a result the satellite maybe ages
in literally nanoseconds difference
compared to you and i now you may say
well that
means nothing yeah but for exact
accurate time keeping that's absolutely
essential
and so they designed the gps satellites
clocks to actually run a little faster
so that when they're moving and their
clock slows
down by the fact that they are moving
just like interstellar they are now in
sync with your clock
which means they're going to accurately
measure that
if scientists were not being if they
didn't account for this
time delay this or this time we call
dilation
your your mobile fine gps could be out
as much as five ten kilometers
and you think about it five ten
kilometers if you're lost in a bush or
lost somewhere
that's a significant difference that you
don't want
so um so although interstellar is a bit
mind-boggling we know it to be true
we have the experiments that verify this
and you know our technology
relies on it so so is it the farther you
get away from
earth the slower you age
it's actually about your speed it's
about your speed and how
there's two things that affects this
time change
one is your speed so if i were to travel
really fast compared to you if you were
to measure my time
it would be slower uh the story i give
to my students
is this is let's say there's a nearby
star our closest
star apart from our sun by the way is
what referred to as proxima centauri
now proxima centauri is about 4.3 light
years away
now that means light travels 4.3 years
just
to get from there right so
you know if that star were to go dead
right now
we wouldn't find out about it for
another 4.3 years because it takes 4.3
years
for the light to get to us right so
that's how far our nearest star is
now let's say you decide to well
how about i decide because i think i'm a
few years older than you how about i
decide
to travel to alpha centauri
but i can't travel on the spaceship
let's say that's
at that speed but i can at least travel
at a fraction of the speed of light and
let's say it takes me five years to get
there not 4.3
and i go there and i come back and i've
been gone
according to my clock ten years five
years to
five years back right but
because i've been moving relative to you
my time
ticks a little slower which means when i
return
i would look at my watch and say hey
danny i've been gone for 10 years
and you'll say no paul you've been gone
for 14 years
and you would have aged 14 years and i
would have aged 10 years and our age
gaps gone a bit closer
all right so that's what we call time
dilation so that
time is a shift right it's because
there's movement between you and i
again that sounds weird it absolutely
sounds weird
but the experimental evidence is there
to support it
it's you know science is weird sometimes
we just don't know but it happens that
way
um and so that's the motion that we have
the other aspect that affects time is
your
closeness to a gravitational field so
the fact that our satellites in orbit
that gps satellites are
moving is one factor that changes the
time
but it's also the fact that gravity is
different
where they are than where we are and so
that also affects it and that's why for
example
in the case of um you know matthew
mcconaughey in interstellar
he was moving right
close to this black hole and if you
remember in the movie
they talked about going to one of these
planets which were closer
in to gargantuan which was the name they
gave to that black hole
and they reckoned hold on if we stay out
here
we're going to lose so many years but if
we move
closer to gargantuan and come back again
we're going to lose decades difference
you know and therefore they had to make
it really short time to get to that
planet there and back
right and and so again
that because the gravitational strength
is stronger closer to the planet and
that affects
how time works as well wow so
you know yeah that's how it works it's
super fascinating